here are things that people can say
that's like what you've done before
and i can actively aggressively avoid
them and steer away from them or i can
say what do i want to do what would i
like it to be
the characters come so much from people
that we've known and um
and from little aspects of ourselves and
the setting is so familiar to us
and then there's sort of thematic stuff
that's personal to us and i just don't
think there's any way that i would
find a script that would mean as much to
me almost every character in any movie
i've ever made is based on
somebody in real life or based on a
combination of real people
so even if i take it to a slightly odd
place
to me those are all real people in and
they're characters that
that mean something to me beyond that
i'm not interested in the quirks i'm
interested in
the whole some of the of the character
whatever is
whatever is coming from my imagination
is probably
you know inspired by my background and
my own whatever
psychology or something so i'm sure that
without me controlling it or choosing to
i'm in the movies
i mean are you are you feeling after
these 15 years or so that there is a
theme or a
sense of what a wes anderson movie is or
is that an outside perception
well i bet i probably it's probably
better for me if it's and if it's if it
stays in outside perception because the
more i think about it the
more confused i get i think um
but that definitely i've i try to
i you know i have the choice of saying
here are things that people can say
that's like what you've done before
and i can actively aggressively avoid
them
and steer away from them or i can say
what do i want to do
how what would i like it to be and i
have these choices with this part of the
story and this one
feels like the most powerful to me or
the most
meaningful to me but it also reminds me
a lot of
the scene between gene hackman and
angelica houston or you know
something and i have tended to say i
think i would rather just do what i
like you know and accept
that um there's might be some very clear
threads and things that are going to
connect
these my movies together and that that
will be okay with some people and
annoying to other people like that the
thing that got me my first
the chance to make a a feature film was
i had made a short film
owen wilson and i we went to school
together and um
and we had written a script and we made
uh we
in fact we thought we were making a
feature we had a few thousand dollars
that we
borrowed from our fathers uh four
thousand i think
and we we shot we started shooting our
movie and it we ran out of money and
we'd only made
we only gotten 10 or 12 minutes of movie
but we just called that a short
and we showed that to some people we
managed to to get that in the right
hands and um that was how i got the
chance to
direct a movie you you knew immediately
no no i'm not going to do it like that i
want to do it this way
uh yes well i i mean i i think i uh
you mean during doing bottle rock
playing bottle rocket yeah during
yeah well that's the funny thing i feel
like i was never more confident in my
life than when we made that film
yeah and never less confident than when
we screened it um the first time we
screened it was the
was was part two of my life um
because up to that point i really my
attitude was
just wait till they see this right and
um
and i and a lot of people were you know
what does this story
hold together or you know is this people
gonna understand why these boys are
acting like this and everything i think
they're gonna understand
it's pretty funny um and um
and then we screened it in at in you
know you've heard me tell this many
times i
suppose but maybe they relive it yes um
we screened it in santa monica at the
amc
17 or something like that on the third
street promenade for an audience
for an audience of 400 people
and um and as the reels
unspooled you know during the
i watched i was sitting in the back row
with all the studio executives everybody
and um
and i began to see people leaving
and they you know they were leaving in
groups
um people don't go to the bathroom in
groups
um they're not coming back you know they
take their coats
and um and it became you know really
excruciating um i i went at a certain
point i left
i tried to be very discreet about it
because i didn't want to add to the
to the to the exodus feeling
but i also couldn't take it and um and i
watched i went up to the projection
booth and watched and they just left
all through the film and um and it was
really
uh a miserable thing um and
um but i remember there was a there was
a
we afterwards we had the audience cards
you know the reactions
and you know they just you know you get
thing
s-u-c-k-d
um you know that's the sort of
thing you got um and a lot of things
where if favorite whatever
none you know one after another uh
and um and but i remember that we were
going through it you know and
and uh and i was kind of analyzing it
everyone's feeling
bad for me uh that i won't be able to do
this with my life
and um and and then i remember there's
one then i got
one of these and it was like a you know
outline of a dissertation
this girl had sat there a lot
uh longer than everybody else and she'd
written a whole thing and she quoted
things and she said that stuff and i was
like
and i remember in the room i was like
this is our audience
i mean it was only there was literally
one
positive thing um and um
and i didn't get the you know i was like
this she's so good she's
she's getting everything um a few years
later
several years like six years later um i
was at like uh
some kind of uh function and uh
this girl you know some kind of film
thing or it's a dga thing or something
and this girl
is afterwards and introduced herself to
me and says i was at your screening and
saying
i was like i know who you are i know
exactly who you are
and she was uncomfortable she wasn't
sure what i was like no no i know you
we made rushmore in my high school
um so the strongest association for me
is being
back in class essentially you know
literally in the same classrooms
um and you know it's the only move it's
one of the few
experiences i've had where i've you know
we had written these scenes but all
these scenes
i was picturing the exact spots where we
shot it
i i didn't expect to shoot the movie in
texas even and in fact at one point we
had found a school in scotland
that we thought might be better um and
um you know we were
looking all over the place in the end
the thing that probably strikes me
the most forcefully when i think back on
it is just that i was
went home secret i don't know
i think you just got to find something
you love to do and then do it for the
rest of your life
and looking back i don't even know how
we managed to get rushmore
made or why because you know bottle
rocket we'd spent many years
making this movie well virtually no one
saw it
then rushmore was more expensive and
uh maybe even a bit stranger
and yet it seems just
happen um so um i think it was just
lucky um but i guess also i mean we did
spend a lot of we spent years
working on the movie putting it together
um but i feel like
when when we made bottle rocket i felt
a uh confidence about what i was doing
um that i never really had again uh
once we showed the movie publicly and i
saw that people
could reject this completely which they
which is exactly what happened
um that changed my perspective
permanently about what it's like to
to you know to bring a movie to an
audience and what you can expect
but it didn't make me change how i went
about
doing rushmore i mean once bottle rocket
was finished and suddenly someone said
we'll do another one then
then that was what i was really focused
on because it's
ideas of characters characters studies
come up
scenes come up moments come up and it
kind of evolves into the plot correct
well it you know it depends most of
these movies i've done
it would probably be an exaggeration to
say they have a plot
any one of them this new one i think
does
i mean this one actually has this
happens and then this happens and then
this happens and it's all
connected um but um
but i would say that to make a movie
you know to make a good movie in most
cases
you need a lot of ideas and you need a
lot of material and it's not and you
know
to keep it going for 90 minutes or 95
minutes or two hours or whatever it is
um you've got it's got it's got to hold
a lot of a lot of information and a lot
of feeling and
um and observations about
whatever it is um so um so for me you
know
even even if you have kind of even if
you have a plot
you've still got to fill it with things
and you've got to build up something and
you've got to
kind of research and gather ideas and
you have to write your own scripts
i mean so far everything you've made
you've written
yes two right it's two but so uh it it i
i mean i feel i i haven't read anything
that felt i mean these these are
pretty personal movies like this movie
rushmore is very personal to me and owen
it's what does that mean personal
it's got enough it's got so many little
things that connect to our own lives you
know
the characters come so much from people
that we've known and um
and from little aspects of ourselves and
the setting is so familiar to us
and then there's sort of thematic stuff
that's personal to us and i just don't
think there's any way that i would
find a script that would mean as much to
me you say thematic stuff that's
personal to us what do you mean
i mean like the kid in the kid the
movie's about is someone who
he doesn't try you know like in high
school
one of the central things is to be cool
yeah and this is a kid who's not cool
at all but who is who but who is um
he has his own ideas the way he wants to
be things he wants to kind of accomplish
and he has this great enthusiasm for
those things and this kind of drive
about it and a resilience
and and i sort of kind of that that's
something that means something to us i
mean i like people who are
kind of unusual characters and kind of
originals
and so did it feel different for you i
mean did you make mistakes
perhaps and thinking this would work and
it didn't or that it wouldn't work
and something did well the thing i
definitely didn't
anticipate i thought we finished the
script
and um you know we had finished we had
been done for a while we'd done lots of
revising and
finessing and it was done and i thought
we're going to now record the actors
and that's going to be done and then
we're going to storyboard it
and then we'll shoot it but everybody
told me
but when you do an animated film you
know all you i think
with most animated films they start
storyboarding and doing temporary
recordings before they've even finished
the script necessarily and they keep
revising the script
with the storyboards and working through
it and i thought well
that's not how we're doing it because
we've already got the script
but that was exactly what happened we
started re i mean as soon as it was done
this doesn't quite make sense and all of
a sudden you have a freedom to not just
edit it you and you know to figure out
how you're going to solve your problems
you can say well you know what would
actually be better is if these three
scenes were just
two lines and rather than you know they
don't they don't even have to go over
here
and in fact it might have more weight if
we
if we if we expanded this part of the
story
and all of a sudden you know it becomes
you know for two years
it's being it's being rewritten and
re-recorded and re-storyboarded and
you know in fact i i wrote a lot of new
scenes and we added characters and uh
and diddle did made a lot of changes but
but
but um you know the the thing with this
kind of movie is it's there's there's
time to work on everything you know
we don't have 20 guys in the room but i
had time to you know to work on
everything in it um because you know
there's
really two solid years of one form of
production or another
dreams that all mirror what your films
look like well my sleeping dreams
i don't even really remember but my
dreams as
for instance the last movie i made which
is
moonrise kingdom it's called that that
one i think is
really based on a fantasy i had as a kid
you know
i've drawn some things from my own
childhood but the main thing is
a sort of dream i had as a child of of
of a romance that didn't actually happen
that's really the inspiration for the
movie
i often ask people if we were to take
all of their body of work and put it
together and then look at it what would
they tell us about them
and so i wonder with your body of work
if i put it together would i have a
better understanding of who you are
yeah probably i mean you know i don't
know if you have a better understanding
but you'd have
a lot of information about me i think
anyway
however we however one would interpret
it i don't know
um but i think um you you know the
movies i've made
which now a lot i mean i've been doing
this stuff for years i think i've made
eight or
so movies they're all they're all
these movies are made up from scratch
they're not adapted from anything
so i and although i've always worked
with
a writing partner different people in
each movie there's
some degree to which whatever is
whatever is coming from my imagination
is probably
you know inspired by my background and
my own whatever psychology or something
so i'm sure
that without me controlling it or
choosing to
i'm in the movies i think that's me
responding
to somebody criticizing me for uh making
the same movie over and over again
probably which i get um
and i think it's you know it's because i
deal with the similar themes but i don't
usually think about themes when i'm
writing and i and they're probably
connections among the kinds of
characters
i use a lot of the same actors over and
over again and i guess there's visual
stuff that
you can link from one movie to another
way i mean a lot of things that i do the
same way every time
but it's just the way i like it and i
and i feel like it's a mistake for me
not to do it not to do that if i feel
like i if i feel like i have an idea
what the best
thing is for the story i would just want
to follow that
um even if it does mean that you know
people can tell it's me
is what else you said people who like
weird people i guess are more likely to
like my films and people who call people
weirdos
yeah i stand behind weird people it's
well it's it's kind of hard for me to
understand me and the way i phrase that
but i think i get it and i
and i agree with it you like people i
you know i mean i could i would say
people who call people weirdos not
people you like i i well i would say i
mean i'm sure i call people weirdos all
the time but i think
may but probably what i'm what i'm very
in a very odd way
and trying to get at is um that i don't
think i don't think
like people always refer to my movies as
quirky and they think the characters are
weird
and for me i can i can understand that
point of view about them but
almost every character in any movie i've
ever made is based on
somebody in real life or based on a
combination of real people
so even if i take it to a slightly odd
place
to me those are all real people and
they're characters that
that mean something to me beyond that
i'm not interested in the quirks i'm
interested in the whole
sum of the of the character if your
movies are weird people are weird
yeah the first idea for the movie
had nothing to do with the setting it
had to do with this one
character uh played by ray fines
mr gustav in our story and he is
inspired by
an old friend hugo my friend hugo and i
made
made the script together and our friend
was the model for this character and
immediately
as we started writing it i began to
think you know i have wanted to work
with ray
fines for for some years and i started
thinking
i would love to write this part for rafe
um
in the end i really don't know who else
could play this
um and nor would i want to see anybody
else play it
um but um but that's what it began with
and then um we combined that with my
kind of feeling that i would like to do
something in that was
in an in our own invented version of
eastern europe i had not traveled around
so i had not spent this kind of time in
that part of the world before
and when we had written the script we
had written the story where there's this
hotel
in the say the 30s and it's um
at its peak and um
it's at its most popular and
then in the 60s let's say the
the place is um is it has
fallen out of favor it's kind of uh
falling apart
and um it's in decline but
traveling around in eastern europe going
to going to places like the the hotel
gelart in uh in budapest in particular
and
traveling around in czech republic to
karlovy very
and um and in prague um
we realized that we were missing
something which is
which is a layer of history in the
architecture
communism um it's very
present when you visit these places you
see it you see the old place and the
newer place inside it
and then the newer period inside of that
all these layers still exist so we
changed our story a bit without really
rewriting it it was in the design and
the architecture of our movie
we sort of automatically started to
build in something about the
history through the architecture
you